behold one of the most absurd articles
you will ever see from the week why are
republicans so concerned about grooming
i just want to i just want to pause real
quick what a great question
this headline
should make it clear to any and everyone
that there are two distinct universes
that exist in terms of morality
there is no conservative post-liberal
libertarian civil libertarian whatever
who would question why grooming is bad
but apparently to the establishment left
to the corporate left democrat whatever
and many leftists who would defend this
they're outright just like why are you
mad about your kids being groomed
yeah
yeah the morality is just it's just it's
it's parallel realities the most the
most charitable possible interpretation
you can give to this article is that
he's essentially saying that this
grooming isn't happening and it's moral
hysteria right that seems to be what he
delineates in this article so yeah
here's the question why would
republicans be concerned about grooming
is it the case that florida tried to
pass or did pass a parental rights and
education bill that said you can't talk
to 48 year olds about sexuality then
tell them don't tell your parents after
you have a conversation with them about
sexuality and perverted ideas then the
entire media said that that was wrong
and we should oppose it i think oh wait
it is so it's perfectly reasonable but
let's make sure we we we preface this
with
there was a bill that was passed in
florida
there it says classroom instruction
on orientation and identity is
prohibited kindergarten through third
grade or in a matter that is not age
appropriate it further clarifies that in
any instance of treatment given to a
child for mental medical or physical
reasons the parents must be informed and
the school and its employees can't
encourage children to withhold
information and must provide information
to parents on certain issues the parents
have a right to sue how now when that
happened what did the establishment
media come out and say
yo why do you hate gay people yep and i
was like whoa whoa wait hold on hold on
a minute you know we're like hey we
don't we don't like you know creepers
coming after our kids and they're like
you hate gay people it's like
that that association happened in your
mind yes
yeah like this is it reminds me you know
the kevin spacey thing when he was you
know accused of uh of pedophilia and he
was like let me admit i am a gay man
what
that's right very bold right very bold
so this is i think you know they tried
what actually was extremely reckless uh
rhetorical gambit right same thing for
spacey though it was just assaulting
dudes i don't think they were kids i
think i think they were like teenagers
were they underage i'm pretty sure yeah
that there was some reports of him
trying to like seduce underage males oh
yeah yeah oh that's the case yeah so uh
that would that was why it was like i'm
going to admit i'm a gay man was such a
joke right yeah like everyone's like did
you do it and he goes i'm gay yeah
they're like
okay not responsive bro don't know what
that's to do so yeah right so here's
what i would say about this article
i i'm i'm not uh uh interested in
trying to give the benefit of the doubt
to people who would call all of us
fascists or nazis our white supremacists
so when they read an article that says
why republicans so concerned about
grooming
do they not realize what they're saying
with that headline to the average person
yeah does the average person understand
they're talking about a semantic debate
and i'm not going to go ahead and assume
that he actually writes in the article
that it's hard to know how much of this
is sincere hysteria and how much is ugly
mccarthyist politics or uh how about
this dude is so out of touch the left is
so in favor of grooming they can't see
it as grooming or being bad that's what
i'm saying i think this spawns from uh
guidance counseling in high school went
out to high school it was like if you're
getting abused at home you can come talk
to the guidance counselor and the guy in
confidentiality they'll report it to the
police for you kind of thing so like
your parents aren't going to destroy you
for and that's why i think this
mentality is like if you think you're
trans and you're six then they're that
we don't want then it's abusive for your
parent to tell you it's not mentality
and so they're trying to do this behind
the parents back because they don't want
the kids but suffer abuse but it's not
it's not the same thing it's not abuse
look these parents are going to be with
these children for 79 years well
probably the parents will die before
then but let's just say average life
expectancy 55 years average you know 55
to 60 years the parents will be with
their children their entire lives how
about that the teachers one year
one year so how about if a five to nine
year old says something the teacher says
maybe this is something that's best
suited for your parents to figure out
with you because they're gonna be with
you for the next decade then you know as
you go through these issues in school
your your parents will be a constant for
the entirety of their your school career
or whatever will only be one year out of
the whole the entire time the kid goes
but i'm afraid to tell my parents and
then so it spawns from that and it's
like well they're afraid we can't make
them do something the teacher should say
you should never be scared of your
parents a good teacher would do that but
if parents are beating their kids then
they should say we're gonna call you
know child services right a good faith
exception sort of ends up swallowing
like the normal behavior right and
again like the arrogance here of these
teachers to be like well no i should be
able to talk about you know instruct
these kids on sexual orientation and i
should be able to have secret
conversations about their gender
identity like no no no no this is not
your child
there's a parent and i think it's not a
surprise that all these people are like
single or or childless why are
i i got to i got to go at this semantic
argument real quick obviously people are
going to argue on the left that the the
article is not suggesting that they
don't understand why grooming is bad
they talk about all that stuff in there
the the article itself is trying to
separate what grooming means
into something else yes that's why it's
on quotes what they're trying to do is
when when when uh it's again i hate
saying conservatives trying to redefine
it you're right already they're trying
to redefine what the word means when we
see photos of there's that photo of that
little boy with the adult naked man you
remember that one yeah and and it's like
a drag show and the left was like this
is fine and i'm like the dude is buck
naked or there's the the desmond kid who
is stripping on stage but that's just a
dredge i'm like no it's not if anyone
who's ever been to across this country
and knows what strip clubs are like
there are fully clothed strip clubs
where the wind can't get naked there are
topless bars and there are fully nude
bars that means strip clubs actually
have exist where the women just take off
their clothes to their under layers
which is exactly what that little boy
was doing they are doing child stripping
and they're like how's that grooming
when when conservatives post liberals
whatever this faction is says we don't
want teachers having conversations about
sexual concepts to children it's just
that because you because this is what is
being what they're pushing for when they
then come out say what could they
possibly mean by grooming yeah so no
they're lying it's interesting they kind
of answer their own question here and i
want to make another point first on this
whole uh point about not being sure how
much a sincere hysteria and how much is
ugly mccarthy's politics that's rich
coming from a member of the party which
spent years calling us russian agents
for disagreeing with them
but they still then they still do so in
this article he says
that this is dishonest because most
americans will hear the term referring
to groomer and understand it to mean
something much more violent than quote
encouraging kids to question their
sexuality in the church unquote here's
the thing if you ask most americans
how they would label an adult
encouraging a child to question their
sexuality and then telling their child
not to speak to their parent about the
conversation they would label that
grooming it is a completely fair term in
fact it is the most accurate possible
term to use in that situation never you
ever watch uh law order svu yes
justice system that's right and there
are many episodes where there'll be like
a child victim and they'll be like did
anyone tell you not to talk to your
parents did anyone tell you you won't
get in trouble if you tell us because
groomers go to kids and say don't tell
your parents i told you if there's a 16
year old that comes up to your kid on
the sidewalk and tells them
you'd probably see people go irate but
if it's a teacher now all of a sudden
there is an argument that it's okay if
it's a teacher doing it and not a 16
year old neighborhood bully like weirdo
coming up and doing it on the street
what's the freaking difference man like
stay mad you know again right you know
the fact that there's conservatives who
finally we have like this rhetorically
very potent like description grooming
and yeah i mean i do think it create has
there's a connotation to the extent this
article is correct i think there is a
connotation of like sexual predation in
it but that's not the only that narrow
definition is not the only thing that
grooming means that it you know
encompasses the idea is you start slow
that's the point but the issue with this
bill in florida is that when it's it's
literal grooming it's not conspiracy and
and what they're trying to do now is
this guy even says you know it's q anon
and then they try saying like oh here we
go the republicans are all q anon and
it's like why and they're like
republicans are accusing democrats of
being pedophiles and it's like
when um well hold on there a minute when
someone comes out and is like uh i would
prefer it if the teachers didn't have
conversations with children about sexual
issues and then tell them to keep it a
secret and they go yo why do you hate
gay people i'm just like
first of all
what and why are you why are you
defending that
yeah
in the literal definition
you know what it's just very very simple
the left redefines words and what
they're trying to do right here
is they're trying to take the word
grooming which is what is happening and
they're trying to take this one piece
and move it out and move the goal post a
little bit like oh no no this isn't
really grooming republicans are lying
because technically if someone's having
secret sexual conversations with
children that doesn't count because
we're talking about lgbtqia stuff i mean
this is but this is something they
always do right when it's an epithet
that applies to their ideological
adversaries we're going to broaden the
definitions so that it encompasses their
behavior when it's a definition that
applies to our ideological allies we're
going to narrow the definition so it
doesn't apply i mean racism is the
classic example like the redefinition of
racism is first structural so it
encompasses everything in society but
then prejudice plus power and narrowing
it so that when our ideological allies
do things that are overtly racist it
actually no longer becomes racist
applies to them right like it's just
it's just lane it's just word games
right and so you know and all of a
sudden they're mad that republicans have
a word that is just getting traction
like and then the worst thing we have
washington general type republicans like
you know i don't even would call david
french republicans
in general right um but saying like oh
no we shouldn't use this word it's like
no this is a very it's an one it's
effective and two it's perfectly
justified you know the funniest thing
was uh shout out to robbie suave from uh
he's from reason right and he was he
said something like it's weird that
people are saying students should know
anything about their teachers lives
something like that was that was that
yeah it was yeah i knew nothing about my
teachers lives but especially in those
ages the weirdest sophistry i've ever
heard like no one cares no one is
arguing students shouldn't know about
their teachers lives they're like you
know i don't i don't care if the kids
know the teacher has a boyfriend i care
if the teacher is like gather around
children and let me explain to you
classroom instruction on these issues
and you're five years old it's like i
don't know if you've seen recent sound
part but mr garrison has been talking
about his like gay relationship in the
third grade class like that's the reason
i mean he's always done that right yeah
like it's literally like but that's i
think that's ultimately what they're
trying to do south park or south park
yeah there there's the remember remember
the episode where um mr garrison
uh uh he transitions he becomes a trans
woman
and then he goes on a date
and then he comes in he's in and
mrs garrison is all angry
because all men are pigs and then tells
them they have to do weekend book report
on the old man in the sea
and it was like the south park actually
made jokes about the idea that the
teacher would be yelling at the kids
about sexual personal issues and that
was supposed to be comical in that it's
not real life yeah i think a lot of kids
saw that and it just wrote code in their
brain that it was real that's the
problem with parody and if that cartoon
was not a cartoon was like a real life
show i think people can it's not the
children children
adults tiny kids can't tell the
difference between comedy and okay well
hold on you're talking about something
totally talking about the kids that are
now teachers were watching that crap
back in the day and thinking it was
writing in their brain like bro this was
this is normal this is normal like 10 10
years ago yeah exactly so they were like
10 but um
they're not 20 years
if south park was a real show with real
actors
that scene wouldn't have flown it would
have been shut down by the aclu or
whoever would have went after him hard
but because the cartoon all of a sudden
you can do this grotesque comedy and i
will say one of the weirdest things
about south park is that like they have
overtly sexual situations between 10
year olds on that show all the time i
always thought that was weird but you
know
i i think that's for adults like it's
it's it's a show about kids for adults
like
and the kids aren't necessarily
meant to be in childish situations
they're often in adult situations still
i i i find that weird that
it's just a weird circumstance with with
the show but considering the show isn't
overtly about that i'm kind of like
whatever we got big mouth too
they animate it and it's like okay it's
just a joke because it's animated but
it's still training people when south
park does one joke about butters and
cartmen and it's supposed to be like
shockingly grotesque and offensive i'm
like man they really pushed the line on
this one but the show isn't overtly
about this i think when big mouth is
literally a show about children engaging
in sexual activities i'm like why would
someone want to watch that you made a
great point that it's a show about kids
for adults that's very important it's
like an r-rated cartoon yeah so is so is
big mouth and big mouth also is messed
up
i mean there are some things that are so
depraved that they shouldn't be on top
have you ever seen big mouth no i cannot
understand why people are like i look i
got to tell you man like i was saying
early on the moral universes are just
distinct yeah yeah
big mouth is basically a bunch of kids
going through puberty and there's the
puberty monster it's a male and a female
and they're always trying to encourage
them to do these things or whatever i've
seen a couple episodes because i went to
someone's house who was playing it and i
immediately was like yo this is like a
nasty show bro i don't want to see a
show even if it's cartoon characters
there's like a 12 year old boy beating
it in a in a bathroom and like that's
the joke i'm like that's not a joke
that's just gross
where people want to watch that
hey hey man look maybe i'm a square
these days
no it's disgusting i thought the same
thing when i saw that show look at
cuties i think there's a there's a trend
here with what they're doing yeah like
and they defended that to the death too
they defended cuties like crazy yeah
well and for a little while on the left
they were calling this what pedophilia
hysteria and now we're seeing a little
bit of a resurgence of that and what
people are concerned about with the
response to this bill isn't that it was
just some small handful of particularly
perverted teachers who took issue with
it it's that the entire dominant media
culture came out against it and said oh
of course adults have the right to have
secret conversations about sexual
matters with children
that's sick
it's not a moral panic to say that
there's something deeply wrong with the
social fabric of this country and we
need to address it it feels like the
term groomer has sparked something in
people and i was telling lydia before it
feels like cold water splashed on these
people's faces the way they're reacting
to it like they're shaking they're
afraid and they're like why is this even
like the guy's article that we just read
he wasn't saying that the the the
conservatives are wrong for saying
grooming he's like what's the big deal
about like he's genuinely asking the
question because he wants to figure it
out somebody super chatted us this they
said um why is everyone forgetting about
the gay men's chorus will convert your
children i was just gonna mention that
and and it's like they said it was the
group defended itself calling the video
tongue-in-cheek humor but it's like yo
you said we're coming for your children
you think we'll corrupt your kids if our
agenda goes unchecked funny justice once
you're correct we'll convert your
children happens bit by bit quietly and
subtly and you'll barely notice it you
can keep them from disco warn about san
francisco make them wear pleated pants
we don't care we'll convert your
children we'll make them tolerant and
fair and then they say we'll convert
your children someone's got teaching
them not to hate we're coming for them
we're coming for your children we're
coming for them we're coming for your
children and then they like they do
and then people are like please don't
and they're like you hate gay people
yeah well or those examples of teachers
on tick tock going on about how they are
going to educate your child on being
non-binary and alternative sexual
lifestyles can you imagine if some
conservative group made this video but
about conversion therapy or something or
christianity would be completely deleted
off the internet where is it where's the
christian version yeah yeah we're gonna
teach your children values and make them
worship the lord and all that stuff
they'd freak out maybe they'd lose their
minds yeah no the reason they're so
upset is because we're over the people
are over the target they've like
accurately taken this sort of like
massive amount of like untoward behavior
by teachers by like adults of all kinds
right that should be in should not be
happening and they've labeled it with
something they branded it and it's now
it's it's a really really sticky brand
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there